prima di cominciare video questo è un
cerotto perché mi sono tagliato e non
avevo cerotti più piccoli bene questo
non sto morendo stacy l'altro giorno
ciccio che molti di voi conosceranno
perché ogni presente nei miei hunger
games gianandrea di orion web da bing
che io conosco come ora dobbiamo
stronzate quindi non perché avete
cambiato nome malizia perché è family
free bravi e crew a 89 anche giampiero
giampiero lo escludo se abbiamo giocato
a bomba che questo gioco da tavolo dove
c'è una bomba che ci passiamo a tutti
quanti a turno c'è questo mazzo tutte
ski la carta ci sono due lettere e tu
devi trovare una parola che abbia quelle
due lettere in mezzo che hai quando
trovi la parola passi la bomba
all'avversario quando esplode la bomba
la persona che ha la bomba e che non ha
trovato una parola in tempo perderla
partiamo questa parte la saltiamo è
ciccio opportunità ha già dimenticato
una regola bisogna tirare il dato e se
esce non esce tic tic la parola non deve
iniziare con quelle lettere lì ma deve
avere quelle lettere nel mezzo quindi ad
esempio non può essere il tipo
mattarello perché inizia con matt ma
deve essere di averlo in mezzo quindi
sbattare se ti esce l'altro l'altra
opzione sul dato la parola deve iniziare
con quella è e non può averlo in mezzo
il contrario mandare era quella che
avvolge tutti avessero detto a caso per
spiegarlo ma avevo detto veramente così
ma che c'è un vocabolario molto molto
molto poco
re matto almeno era allegra come parole
no all'esame di maturità avevo meno
tensione ve lo giuro
ap ovunque vuol dire che lo puoi mettere
sia all'inizio che in mezzo alla frase
al campanello
era venuta la tipa di sotto a dirci
state zitti che ho urlato e capisco
perfettamente anche gioco estate
giocarle dal piano di sotto provava a
dare la soluzione alle parole
addirittura adesso ci odiamo sia messina
che ha milan 3 2 nel caso vi stesse
chiedendo se ci sarà il mio culone
all'aria per tutto il resto del video la
risposta è sì camminato e calze sexy
quando vado a casa di amici quando sto a
casa mi vesto meglio parlare com'è
possibile che a nessuno sia venuto in
mente al akhbar come tra noi cinque più
la monna lisa nessuno si è accorto
disputati dalla parziale se c'è questa
cosa poi mette cosa c'è con razzi marzia
che la ragazza di pipa marco quando
pensa sembra che debba scorreggiare da
un momento all'altro ce lo sforzo
intestano park tango mago othelma brilla
[Musica]
ma come un idea non sa che cosa mi è
venuto in un area non potevo prendere
punto io dopo aver detto gonorrea tra
contrasti coercitivo da tanto strobo
frenare ma ha posto fine alla sua vita
varrà quanto triste e quanto goduto
gianandrea tra l'altro assolutamente no
tu sei grasso l'espressione di
gianandrea quando la gente si insulta
impagabile lo capite perché io lo adoro
questo metallo e tra tutte le parole che
potranno venirmi in mente quali mi sarà
mai venuta secondo voi prime rimettere
vero marco rimettono è bello così
semplice come domanda che non capisco
cosa possa servire una parola per usarla
poi c'è quella parte di rim e è
giustissima e tra l'altro anche verso
con questa parola hai perso con
rimettere
stavo buttando giù tutto perché c'era la
videocamera su treppiede li stavo
buttando tutto nessuno se n'è accorto
nessuno calcareo posso fare una domanda
come mai all'inizio del video i capelli
erano a posto in questo momento si è
creato un varco sembra che mi sia
photoshoppato i capelli togliendomi un
pezzo di testa e sapendo per che cosa
uscito da quella bocca rispetto al video
di prima col senno di poi la bomba non
l'avrebbe toccata più tantissimo
canestrelle 4.000 iscritti conferiscono
poteri ad esempio posso presentarmi a
casa degli amici in calzini e vestito
come un cane è tanto nessuno dice niente
schiena pescheria
ma è questa la fascia di marco subito
dopo che ha scoraggiato ma comunque
precisione incredibile gli ho detto la
parola all'ultimo secondo pescheria
ma pure perso marco questa cosa come
prima ceo ciccio e gianandrea altair
ma lei ma favorire smaltire non smaltire
cosa dire snelli realtà io però ho detto
tutto degli assassini con esso prezzo
rascal essere lessico lessa gesso
messaggio stessa per finismo tessera
presso l dottoressa lessico basta
mostrare i piedi che poi un casinò sul
destro e sono due o stavo a due carte
sono a due di fila su arrivato a 4 c'è
però chi c'era che stavo a due carte
due le ho prese tre di fila e karma
perché ho messo il video di marco che
vomita in questo video e lui non lo sa e
olio
[Musica]
io lo faccio è così si segna la fine
della partita sono arrivato terzo su
cinque persone non è neanche troppo male
in realtà però il video vi sia piaciuto
ragazzi è stato bellissimo rivedere
questa partita anche perché io amo
giocare ai giochi da tavolo con gli
amici e fare questo video reaction mi è
piaciuto un sacco in qualcosa di
completamente diverso da ciò che faccio
di solito ma mi è piaciuto veramente
tanto trovate comunque il link completa
video che dura mezz'ora in descrizioni
c'è il ciccio s'è montato mezz'ora di
video c'era nel caso volessero tutto e
io video come sento ragazzi veramente mi
piace anche ai soci vento notizia
rilasciate mi piace ogni mi piace che
mettete un cerotto in più uno mi copre
quasi tutto il collo quindi è se ne
mette altri due di vento maurizio
costanzo prove ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo
ragazzi 1 euro
mou singoli tengo a precisare solo che
il video del momento è stato concesso da
marco ovviamente non l'avrei mai messo
senza il suo consenso è questa frase che
ho detto sempre soltanto a far arrivare
il video a dieci minuti di durata
quindi ciao
[Musica]